foreign
fluid and these structures are situated
adjacent to the ventricle the lateral
ventricle the third and the fourth
ventricle these are known as
telencephalic diencephalic and hindbren
choroid plexus but each of them secretes
cerebrospinal fluid which circulates The
ventricle
CSF can help to maintain intracranial
pressure protects brain from mechanical
damage choroplexus forms the blood CSF
barrier and choroplex has derived
factors can help in neurogenesis there
are different cell types present in
choroplexus like epithelial endothelial
immune and mesenchymal cells and the
choroplexus
forms the blood CSF barrier at a
molecular level this barrier is the
tight Junction between the epithelial
cell and it turns out that chloride
pixels is super important for embryonic
brain development and corrodite plexus
goes perturbed in SARS kovid-2 infection